OPERATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
You're support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare course at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Today's lecture, mostly I want
to talk about what computer
scientists do.
We've sort of been teaching you
computer science in the
small, I want to pull back and
think in the large about, what
do people do once they learn
about computer science?
And then I'll wrap up with a
quick overview of what I think
we've accomplished this term.
So what does a computer
scientist do?
What they really do is,
almost everything.
Graduates of our department,
other departments, have done
things like animation for movies
you've all seen, they
keep airplanes from falling
out of the sky, they help
surgeons do a better job of
brain surgery, that's
something Professor Grimson
has worked on.
All sorts of exciting things.
Mostly what they have in common,
and it's incredibly
varied, what you can do with
computer science, but it all
involves thinking
computationally.
And if I had to use a single
phrase to describe 6.00,
that's the phrase I would use.
The semester is really about
computational thinking.
I think this will be a
fundamental skill used by
everyone in the world by the
middle of the current century.
And it'll be like the, it will
become one of the three r's,
reading writing arithmetic.
And I haven't quite figured I
how to put an r in the front
of it, but sooner or later.
So what is it?
Well, the process is the process
that we've sort of
been advocating throughout
the semester.
You identify or invent
useful abstractions.
Sometimes they're out there,
and we can just pluck them.
Sometimes you have to invent
them ourselves.
We then formulate a solution to
a problem as some sort of a
computational experiment.
Typically using those
abstractions.
Then comes the part that many
you get bogged down in, but
it'll get easier for
you as you go on.
Is to design and construct
a sufficiently efficient
implementation of
the experiment.
And I want to emphasize the
word sufficiently here, in
that it only has to be
fast enough to run
it and get an answer.
And it doesn't have to be
the fastest possible.
We then need to validate the
experimental setup, convince
ourselves that the code is
right, and then run the
experiment, and then evaluate
the results, and
then repeat as needed.
And that's, of course,
the key.
By now you've all learned that
these experiments rarely are
done the first time
you run them.
But of course, this is true of
experiments in biology and
physics and chemistry
and everything else.
But this is the basic process.
And I think, it's a view that's
not universally held,
but I think is the correct view
of what computational
thinking is all about.
It's an experimental
discipline.
So the two a's are abstraction,
choosing the
right abstraction, and operating
in terms of multiple
layers of abstraction
simultaneously.
And that's a little
bit tricky.
Something that you've
worked on this term.
You invent some beautiful, high
level of abstraction.
But then you have to think about
it, and implement it
using the rather low level
abstractions provided by the
programming language.
So we'll do a simulation of,
well, the stock market, we've
looked at it just recently.
And you've got this abstraction
of a stock, and at
one level, when we're thinking
about the market, we think of
a stock abstractly, as something
that has a price
that moves up and down.
But then at the same time, we
say, well, is the movement
Gaussian, or uniform, and we're
operating at a somewhat
different level.
And then at a lower level, we're
asking questions like,
well, how should we
represent it? is?
It a dictionary, is it a list,
that sort of thing.
And we always bounce back and
forth and spend a lot of time
thinking about how the
layers relate.
Now the other thing that's
important, and it really
distinguishes, I think,
computing from a lot of other
disciplines.
Is, we don't just write elegant
descriptions of
abstractions on paper, the
way you say, would do in
mathematics.
But we have to then automate
those attractions.
And we always think in terms of,
how can we mechanize the
abstractions?
And that's the computational
part, in many ways.
How can we do that?
Well, we can do it because we
have precise and exacting
notations in which to express
these models.
So I'll say a few words about
the model of stocks, or a few
words about the model of a
drunk wandering around a
field, but I can't get away
with just the words.
Eventually I have to convert
the words to code.
And that's sort of the
acid test of truth.
Have I really understood
what the words mean?
Because if I don't, I can't
actually convert it to code.
And that's both the cursing
and the bless of being a
computer scientist. It's
the curse because, you
can't fake it, right?
And that's one of the reasons
that many students end up
spending a lot of time in
a course like 6.00.
Because they know whether or
not their program works.
When you write a proof in math,
you can delude we into
thinking it's a solid proof,
when it isn't.
When you write an essay, you
can delude yourself into
thinking it's brilliant,
when it isn't.
But here, you look at what it
does, and it either did what
you thought it would
do or didn't.
And so that means you sometimes
have to work extra
hard, but the blessing is, when
it's done, you really
know you've done it.
And you've got something
useful.
And that's because there's a
machine that will execute your
descriptions.
And that's what makes it fun.
So some examples of
computational thinking.
How difficult is this problem?
That's what we talked about
when we talked about
complexity.
And we talked about, for many
problems, for all problems,
there's an intrinsic difficulty
of solving the
problem with the computation.
Independent of how efficient
your particular solution is.
And then the question is,
how can I best solve it?
Theoretical computer science has
given us precise meaning
to these and related
questions.
Thinking recursively, another
good example.
Where we take a seemingly
difficult problem, and
reformulate it into one which
we know how to solve.
Very often, it's a smaller
instance of
the original problem.
And we say, gosh, this
is hard to solve.
But then we think, well suppose
the list only had two
elements in it, would I
know how to sort it?
Yeah.
Well, then we can build up and
say, therefore I can use that
idea to sort a list
of any size.
As part of this thinking
recursively we learn about
reduction, we learned how to,
say, reduce the problem of
deciding what courses to take to
an optimization problem in
terms of the knapsack problem.
Once we did that, we could say,
oh, we know how to solve
all knapsack problems, dynamic
programming has been around a
long time, we'll just do that.
So we do a lot of these
reductions, in betting,
transformations, transforming
one problem into another, and
simulations.
So some other examples, choosing
an appropriate
representation, modeling the
relevant abstracts of a
problem to make it practical.
And this is the essence of
abstraction that computer
scientists learn, is how to
figure out what's relevant and
ignore what is irrelevant,
or less relevant.
Focus on the important things.
That's an enormous
skill in not only
computing, but in life.
We worry about worst-case
scenarios, damage containment,
error correction, all of this
we talked about, we talked
about debugging, defensive
programming, making sure the
types were right, but again
these are very general things
that we think about.
And we think about the fact,
sometimes, it's kind of a nice
idea, the fact that there exists
really hard problems is
actually a good thing.
Because that's what let's us do
things like use encryption
to get privacy of our data,
or privacy for our
communications, privacy
of our phone calls.
Because we have learned
that some problems are
intrinsically difficult to
solve, and that's what coding
is all about.
Or encryption is all about.
That's a nice thing.
I now want to talk more
specifically about what one
group of computer
scientists does.
And that's my research group.
Which consists of mostly
graduate students, but every
year I try and incorporate a
few undergraduates in it.
We work in the area of medicine,
it's also the area
in which Professor Grimson
does most of his work.
The goal is pretty simple: we
want to help people live
longer and better lives.
Right?
I don't think any of you will
think that's a worthless goal.
But, a second goal is,
we want to have fun
while we're doing it.
Because life is way too short to
do anything that's not fun
for very long.
So we push the frontiers of
computer science, electrical
engineering, and medicine.
Working in close collaboration
with physicians, and here
you've got logos of some
of the hospitals
with which we work.
It is, of course, fairly
technical work.
We use machine learning,
clustering, data mining,
algorithm design, signal
processing.
And everything we do ends up,
eventually, getting translated
to code which we then run.
And so we worry a lot
about software
systems and the quality.
We do write systems that, for
example, inject electrical
signals into people's brains.
And it's kind of important,
when you do that, that the
software does what it's
intended to do.
At least if you like
the people.
So some specific activities, and
this is only a sampling.
We work on extracting clinically
useful information
from electrical signals
in the human body.
Mostly the heart, the brain,
and connected anatomy.
For those of you who've never
studied anatomy, I've labeled
the heart and the brain in
the diagram for you.
The two major projects in this
area we've been working on, is
predicting adverse cardiac
events and detecting and
responding to epileptic
seizures.
And I want to say a few words
about each of those.
We'll skip this.
So example one, treating
epilepsy.
I suspect most of you are
surprised by the fact that one
percent of the world's
population has epilepsy.
This is true in almost every
part of the world.
It's true in the United
States, it's true in
underdeveloped countries
in Central Africa.
It seems to be one of the few
diseases that's invariant to
economic situations.
One of the reasons that people
are surprised by this number
is, most folks who
have epilepsy try
to keep it a secret.
There's a long history, getting
back to witches,
people with epilepsy were deemed
to be witches, were
burned at the stake, things
of that nature.
People who have epilepsy are not
allowed by the FAA to work
on maintenance of aircraft.
It's a ridiculous restriction,
but it's in the law, so I know
someone with epilepsy who's kept
it a secret because he
doesn't want to lose his job.
That's a different sermon.
It's characterized by recurrent
seizures, generated
by abnormal electrical activity
in the brain.
It's really less a disease
than a description of
symptoms, because there are lots
of independent, different
causes of it.
It can be inherited, that's
a significant fraction.
Or it can be acquired, typically
by some sort of
insult to the brain.
People who have strokes or
serious infections will
develop epilepsy.
Hemorrhages, and increasingly
head injuries.
Turns out to be an illness
that is of now great
interested the Defense
Department because people are
coming back from Iraq
with epilepsy.
So those of you who don't have
a strong stomach, you might
want to avert your eyes.
Here's one manifestation
of it.
On the left is an EEG, and
that's, in this case, a
recording of the electrical
activity in the surface of
this girl's brain.
You can see she's wearing what
looks like a very funny
looking shower cap.
That's where the
electrodes are.
And it's recording the
electrical activity in the
brain, on the right is
obviously a video.
Well, pretty frightening.
Not all seizures are quite
that frightening.
In fact, most of them are not.
Sometimes people have what are
called absence seizures, where
they just sort of black out
for a period of time.
Still not a good thing if
you're, say, driving a car
when that happens.
The key issue here, is that the
onset of the seizure seems
unpredictable.
And in particular, it seems
unpredictable to the person
who has the seizure.
And that's the real risk.
Seizures are typically
self-limiting.
They will correct themselves
over time.
Eventually this girl will return
to, quote, normal.
The seizure itself will probably
be over in a minute
or two, and for about an hour
she'll be confused, and then
she'll be OK again.
But, because they're
unpredictable, even people who
have as few as, say, two a year,
it dominates their life.
So, if you're that girl, and
even if you're going to have
one of those a year, you're
never going to be
allowed on a bicycle.
Because if that happens when
you're on a bicycle, it's
really bad.
If you're an adult, and you
have one or two year, you
should never drive a car.
Imagine if you've been driving
a car when that happened.
Almost everybody with
epilepsy eventually
suffers a serious injury.
They have a seizure while
they're on a flight of stairs,
and they fall down and
fracture their skull.
They get intra-cranial
hematomas, they get burns if
they're cooking at the stove,
they drown in the bathtub.
And it's the unpredictability
that's bad.
Death is high, two to three
times out of the general
population.
Typically by accident related
to the seizure.
And then there's something
called sudden unexplained
death in epilepsy patients,
SUDEP, which is estimated to
be one per 100 patients
per year.
Just will die, and
no one knows why.
Frequently it will be at night,
while they're in bed,
and the conjecture is, they
have a seizure, and end up
face down in the pillow,
smother, that kind of thing.
So you can imagine, if you're
a parent, you have a child
with this, you don't
sleep much.
Really very sad.
So we want to do something
about that.
And our idea is to detect
the seizure early.
There are two onset times,
electrographic and clinical.
Electrographic is when the brain
first starts looking
suspicious, and clinical is when
there's a overt physical
symptom, that stiffness you
saw in that young girl.
Probably it went by too fast for
any of you to notice, but
if you'd looked carefully at
the EEG on the left of that
picture, you would have seen it
going abnormal before she
had any clinical symptoms.
Because the symptoms are
caused by the electrical
activity in the brain, by
definition, it proceeds the
symptoms, or at least doesn't
follow them.
So our idea was to try
and detect the
electrographic onset.
If you could do this, you
could provide warning.
So you could tell somebody, sit
down before you fall down.
Get out of the bathtub.
Back away from the stove.
Just an oral warning would
be tremendously useful.
You could summon help.
You could tell a parent, come
quick, your child is having a
seizure right now in
bed or elsewhere.
There are fast-acting drugs,
Ativan, which if you inhale at
the start of a seizure, can
stop it, reduce it.
And our particular interest
is neural stimulation.
There is reason to believe, it's
yet to be proved, that if
you apply the correct electrical
stimulation at the
very beginning of a seizure,
you can block it.
Or at least ameliorate
it greatly.
So, here's a picture
of an EEG.
And I'll just point
out, seizures can
be tricky to find.
You might think this is a
seizure, but it isn't.
That's blinking your eyes.
Oh well.
Here is the seizure, but in
fact, it's begun about here.
Where things don't look
particularly ominous.
So it's pretty subtle
to detect.
One of the problems is, EEG
varies across patients.
And epileptics have abnormal
baselines.
Yeah?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Highly variable
in patients, but
that's kind of typical.
But that would be plenty of
time to back away from the
stove, or get off a bicycle.
Not so much time to get off the
Mass Turnpike, if you're
driving a car.
But it would be great,
if you can give 10
or 15 seconds warning.
In fact, if you could give five
seconds warning, it would
be tremendously useful.
And for the treatments, it's
even different, right?
Yes, you're exactly right,
in that particular case.
The problem is, one of the
things I've discovered in
medicine, my work, is that
almost all healthy people look
alike, and all sick people
look different.
So, EEG, if you have epilepsy,
your quote, normal EEG, when
you're not having a seizure,
looks weird compared to people
who don't have epilepsy.
People have been building
seizure detectors for about 40
years now, and they don't
work very well.
Every EEG that gets shipped
comes with a seizure detector,
and the first thing most
hospitals do is, turn it off.
Because it just doesn't work.
The good news is, that even
though each epileptics brain
signals look different, once
you've learned what an
individual's signal looks like,
it's pretty consistent.
Both the interictal, between
seizure, and the
start of the seizure.
Well, that tells a computer
scientist, let's use machine
learning to figure out what that
patient's EEG looks like.
And build a highly specific
detector that will work great
for one person, and not at
all for anybody else.
And then we'll just install
it, and you know, everyone
gets their own.
So instead of one size fits all,
it's design a detector to
fit the patient.
We have been working on this
now for about six years.
We've done, we've looked at
about 80 patients now, more.
And, highly successful.
And I'm not going to weigh you
down with all the statistical
tests and everything, but we've
done the kind of things
I talked about in class.
Looking at the data, doing the
statistics, and suffice it to
say, it works great.
For nine out of 10 patients,
roughly.
And for the tenth, we
just have to say,
sorry, we can't do it.
But, you know, you can't help
everybody all the time.
We're currently, what you see
here, is a picture of a neural
stimulator.
The stimulator itself gets
implanted under the clavicle,
and then a wire runs up and
wraps around the left vagus
nerve, which is the longest
nerve in the human body.
It runs all away from
the head, down
into the lower intestine.
Latin for wanderer.
Does amazing things, like
control whether
you're hungry or not.
Its main, one of its main
functions, is it controls the
parasympathetic nervous
system for the heart.
And it's the nerve that
the brain uses to tell
the heart, slow down.
But, in addition to transmitting
down from the
brain, you can transmit
up the nerve.
And in fact, the left one, for
reasons I don't understand,
translates much better up
than the right one does.
Which transmits much
better down.
So use the left one.
And the notion is, if at the
start of a seizure, we put a
current on that wire, we
stimulate the brain and we
stop the seizure.
That's the theory.
It's been shown to stop
seizures in rats.
But I don't much care
about helping rats.
People purport to have shown it
stops seizures in adults,
or in people.
The level of evidence is,
honestly, ambiguous.
Because what they've done is,
they've implanted it, and they
give the patient a magnet.
And say, when you're having a
seizure, swipe the magnet
across, sorry about that, swipe
the magnet across the
stimulator, it will turn it
on and stop your seizure.
Well, could you imagine that
little girl trying to swipe a
magnet across her chest?
Not likely.
So most people don't
do it successfully.
Some people report, I thought I
was about to have a seizure,
I swiped the magnet and
I didn't have it.
Well, how do we know?
Did they really stop it, or
did they just imagine they
were going to have one?
So it's pretty ambiguous, but
we're now in the process of
doing some real tests
at Beth Israel
Deaconness Medical Center.
And we've been admitting
patients, and controlling the
stimulator, and so far
I'm optimistic.
All right, one more example.
Predicting death.
Well, that's kind of
ominous sounding.
About one and a quarter million
Americans have an
acute coronary syndrome
each year.
That's to say, some sort
of a cardiac event.
A heart attack, or an arrhythmia
of some sort,
various kinds of things,
unstable angina.
And of that one and a quarter
million people, 15 percent to
20 percent of them will die of a
cardiac-related event within
the next 4 years.
Pretty high.
In fact, about 5% within the
next 90 days, there about.
So what do you do?
The key thing, we
have treatments.
We actually know how to treat
most of these things.
But we don't know who to
give the treatments to?
So, for example, who gets an
implanted defibrillator?
Who should be treated
aggressively with statins?
We think we've found a new way
to decide who should get which
of these kinds of treatments.
Something called morphological
variability, which I'll talk
about only briefly.
We've tested it on a fairly
large database.
We have a database with
about 8,000 patients.
We've looked at 2 days for each
patient, each day has 24
hours, each hour has 60 minutes,
each minute has, on
average, 70 heartbeats.
That's a lot of heartbeats.
Over a billion.
So a lot of the techniques we've
talked about this term,
about how do you deal with big
things, I live with every day.
Actually, more accurately, my
students live with every day,
and I commiserate.
But the tests are pretty
convincing.
As an example, they're implanted
defibrillators,
they, too, go under
the clavicle.
Fortunately we have
two clavicles.
And then they connect to the
heart, and they notice, they
have a sensor, they notice the
heart is beating very badly,
and they shock the heart.
So you've all seen medical
shows, where people put
paddles on, say, clear, the
patient goes boom boom, and
then they say, sinus
rhythm restored.
Well, this does the same
thing, but you
walk around with it.
Now, you don't want to turn on
all the time, because as you
can see, it delivers
quite a jolt.
Interestingly, this is an
article from this fall, from
the New York Times, 90 percent
of the people who get one
implanted, and the device itself
costs about $50,000,
let alone the cost
of implanting it.
90 percent receive negative
medical benefit.
How do I know that they received
medical benefit?
Well, I know that 90% of them
are never turned on.
Remember, there's a sensor
that decides whether
to apply the shock.
90 percent of them, the sensor
never says, turn on.
So 90 percent of them can
deliver no benefit because
they're never used.
On the other hand, clearly
having the surgery to implant
this, is some risk.
So that's why the benefit
is not only
neutral, but negative.
You've had fairly serious
surgery, you've risked
infection, and, in fact, this
year several people died.
I think three or four died
when leads broke
off on these things.
So, clearly we're putting in too
many of them, if only 10
percent are used.
On the other hand, roughly
every one minute and 50
seconds, somebody in
this country dies a
sudden cardiac death.
More often once every
two minutes.
100 of them during the course
of this lecture.
If these people all had
defibrillators implanted, many
of them would not die.
So, we have a therapy, we just
don't know who to give it to.
So, what does this look like?
Again, this is pretty
strong stuff.
That's what sudden cardiac
death looks like.
An apparently healthy guy,
suddenly he's dead.
It's things like this that
remind us why we can do real
useful things with our
talents or skills.
So how do you identify
high risk cases?
Lots of different ways, I won't
go through them, but
we're focusing again
on the electrical
signals in the heart.
We're trying to evaluate the
shape of the heartbeat and
what's going on.
I won't go through details,
the only thing I wanted to
point out is, we use
dynamic programming
to actually do this.
So the key idea in our method
depends upon dynamic
programming.
We've evaluated it
several times.
Here's one evaluation.
We took the 25 percent of the
population that we thought was
at the highest risk.
And you'll notice that within,
actually the first 30 days,
4.19 percent of those
people were dead.
This is a retrospective
study, by the way.
The ECG had been recorded, and
we knew, we had follow-ups on
them, and of the people we said
were not, the other 3/4
of the population, a very
small fraction died.
So this is called a Kaplan
Meier curve, and it
shows a huge gap.
And in fact, roughly speaking,
if we think you were at high
risk, you were 8 1/2 times more
likely to die within a
month, within 90 days.
And the good news is, we don't
do this just so we can say,
make your will.
Get your affairs in order.
We actually do this so that we
can say, all right, this is a
person who should maybe get a
defibrillator, maybe should
have their arteries
cleaned out.
Maybe should take
a blood thinner.
Once we know who's at risk, we
can do something about it.
All right, all I want to do is
just give you a flavor of the
kinds of things you've been
learning, are really useful,
and can be used to really do
things that are worth doing.
So wrapping up the term,
what have you learned?
Well, you know, I think
we'll start with this.
If you think what you could do
in September, and what you can
do now, you've really come
a long way, right?
So try and go back and do
problem set number one, and
see how long it takes you now,
and how long it took you then.
You'll discover that you really
are at a place you were
not in September.
We covered five major topics.
Learning a language for
expressing computations,
that's Python.
I already talked about the
importance of having a notation.
Learning about the process
of writing and debugging
programs. But more generally,
learning about the process of
moving from some relatively
ambiguous problem statement.
As you've all noticed in the
current problem set, we left a
lot of things unspecified.
You know, and the email was
flying back and forth, and
often the answer was,
you figure it out.
Because that's one of the things
we want you to learn.
To go from some problem
statement to a computational
formulation.
As a tool to that, you learned
a basic set of recipes, bunch
of different algorithms. And
you learned how to use
simulations to deal with
problems that did not have
nice closed form solutions.
Why Python?
Well, believe it or not, it's
an easy language to learn,
compared to other languages.
Simple syntax, it's
interpretive, which helps with
the debugging, you don't have to
worry about managing memory
as you would in a language
like C. It's modern.
It supports, in a fairly elegant
way, object-oriented
programming and classes, and
it's increasingly popular.
It's used increasing in other
subjects at MIT and other
universities, increasing in
industry, and a large and
ever-growing set of libraries.
We talked about writing,
testing, and debugging
programs. And if I had one
message I want you to remember
about all of this,
it's be slow.
Slow down, take it one step at
a time, take your time and be
methodical, systematic,
and careful.
Understand the problem first.
Then think about the overall
structure of the solution, and
the algorithms independently
of how you're going
to code it up.
So you might say, well, I'm
going to use dynamic
programming.
And that's an independent
decision from Python or Java
or C++ , or anything else
to implement it.
And in fact, it's pretty easy to
translate a well-organized
program from one language
to another.
Break it into small parts, and
we talked about unit testing
and the importance of that.
Nobody can build anything
big in one fell swoop.
So, break it into small parts,
identify useful abstractions,
both functional and data, code
and unit test each part, and
first worry about
functionality.
Are you getting the
correct answer?
And then efficiency.
And a piece of that is, learn
to use pseudo code to help
yourself out.
As I said earlier, be systematic
when debugging.
Think about the scientific
method.
It's not just something that
we use to torture middle
school students.
And when you write a program
and it doesn't work, ask
yourself, why it did
what it did?
Focus on understanding why the
program is doing what it's
doing, rather than why
it's not doing what
you wanted it to?
Because as soon as you know
why it's doing what it's
doing, you'll know
how to fix it.
But if you skip that step,
you'll waste an
awful lot of time.
Going from problem statement
to computation.
We said a lot of this, you
break the problem into a
series of smaller problems.
Ideally, reducing it to a
problem you already have code
to solve, or somebody else's
code to solve.
My first instinct when I have to
solve a problem is, I type,
I go to Google, and I type, I
think about, oh this is really
an x problem, a shortest
path problem.
I type Python shortest path,
and I see what code
pops up on my screen.
But I can't do that until I've
realized, oh, it's really a
shortest path, or it's
really a knapsack.
If I type Python select
courses, I won't
get anything useful.
Think about what kind of output
you'd like to see.
I often start thinking about
a program by first asking
myself, what's the output
going to look like?
And I'll actually write
the output down.
And then I'll see if I can't
write a program to generate
that kind of output.
Often you can take a problem
formulated as an optimization
problem, a lot of thing reduce
to finding the minimum or
maximum values, satisfying
some set of constraints.
So when you're given something
like, how do I find the
directions from here to
Providence, think about it as
an optimization problem.
And also, think about whether
you really have to solve it.
It's very often the case that an
approximate solution is all
you really need.
And they're a lot faster.
So, we think about approximation
formally, in the
sense of, say, Newton Raphson,
we looked at, successive
approximation.
But more informally, an
approximation can be, solve a
simpler problem.
That you don't really need to
solve the problem you thought
needed to solve, if you solve
something simpler, it
will do just fine.
So you don't find the best
solution, you just find a
pretty good solution.
Or you simplify the assumptions
and say, well, I'm
going to find directions, and
to make my problem a little
simpler, I'm not going to allow
myself to take any roads
except highways to get from
city a to city b.
It may not be the shortest, but
it's an easier problem to
solve because are so
many fewer roads.
We talked about algorithms, we
talked about big o notation,
orders of growth, that's
very important.
We talked a little bit about
amortized analysis, that you
might want to, say, sort
something first if you were
going to do a lot
of searching.
We looked at a bunch of
kinds of algorithms.
I've listed them here.
I'm, by the way, going to send
you a list with all this stuff
on it, among other things,
so don't feel you need to
transcribe it.
But a lot of, surprisingly large
number of algorithms, to
cover in one semester, when
you think about it.
Exhaustive enumeration,
successive approximation,
greedy, divide and conquer,
decision trees, dynamic
programming.
Quite a lot.
Specific algorithms and
specific optimization
problems. We spent a lot
of time on simulation.
It's important, but maybe not as
important as all that time,
relative to the semester, but
it gave me an excuse to talk
about some things that
I wanted to cover.
So it gave me a framework to
talk a little bit about
probability and statistics.
And it's my view, personally,
that every MIT student should
be made to take such a course.
Since they're not, I tried
to sneak it in here.
But it's all, it's important
stuff to know.
It gave me an excuse to build
some interesting programs. So,
what I hope you noticed, is as I
went through these things, I
actually tried to develop the
programs incrementally, to
talk about the abstractions,
to talk about how
I would test them.
And so, just as important as the
simulation itself, was the
process of building
the simulation.
And so I just shows that as a
mechanism to go through some
case studies of building some
interesting programs. It let
us talk about random choice.
Much of the world is, or
at least appears to be,
stochastic.
And therefore, we have to model
randomness in programs.
And even we don't have to, it
can be used to solve problems
that are not inherently
random, like finding
the value of pi.
It let us look at the issue
of assessing the
quality of an answer.
We look at things, said, do we
believe that that answer is
right or not?
And building models of, at least
parts of, the world.
Some pervasive themes that
we talked about.
The power of abstraction,
systematic problem solving,
these will be useful even if
you never again write a
program in your whole life.
What next?
Well, many of you, almost all of
you, have worked very hard
this semester.
I hope you feel that you've
got a return on your
investment.
Only you know that.
As I said earlier, take a look
at the problem sets, and see
whether you think you've
learned anything.
I'd like you to remember after
you leave this course, that
you've got a skill you can use
to solve problems. And when
you sit down, and there's some
issue that you don't know,
just knock out a program
to get your answer.
I do it all the time, and
it's very useful.
If you want to take more
courses, there are
others you can take.
6.01, the first course
for Course 6 majors,
you will find easy.
Experience says, people who
take 6.00 first don't
understand what all the
fuss is about 6.01.
You'll also find it fun
and interesting.
6.034, the introduction to
AI, is now using Python.
You know everything you need
to know to take that.
6.005, which is software
engineering, you know
everything you need
to take that.
And, for many of you, you can
take 6.006, which is a really
interesting kind of
algorithms course.
More advanced algorithms,
particularly those you who
like math would find
6.006 really fun.
So if you want to take
more courses, there
are courses to take.
Thank you all, good luck with
the rest of the semester.